Olha só, imagina você ter que comer algo
que te faz passar mal só para fazer um
exame. Pois é, isso que acontece com
quem precisa diagnosticar doença celica
hoje em dia. Mas veja bem, cientistas
acabam desenvolver o novo teste que
resolve esse problema todo. Sabe aquela
pessoa que já tirou o glúten da dieta e
se sente bem melhor? Agora ela não
precisa mais voltar a comer pão e
macarrão, passar mal de novo de
propósito, só para confirmar o
diagnóstico. Esse novo exame detecta a
doença celíaca mesmo sem o paciente
consumir o glúten. Isso é revolucionário
porque muita gente deixava de fazer o
diagnóstico justamente por medo de
voltar a sentir dor abdominal, enjoo,
todas aquelas reações desagradáveis. Com
esse teste, a gente consegue identificar
os anticorpos específicos da doença sem
provocar o sistema imune. É como
descobrir o ladrão sem precisar deixar
ele entrar na casa, entende? M.